I think it's CU JJ Ka is stealing the
spotlight right now with in many ways
many ways good and bad yeah have you
seen the Twitter stuff no all the
animators being like this is hell yeah
oh yeah but they've been saying that for
a while right yeah no but like really
bad now really which I okay here's the
thing I don't know if if this is just
here here's the sad part I don't know if
this is uh a new development or if you
know if this is something that we
probably that has probably always been a
thing and people are just now more vocal
about it because they're more animators
on Twitter you know it's yeah yeah the B
anim is on Twitter and it's also a
really big show yeah yeah I would like
to hope it's not the lad but you never
know I think
if the world is as such that it's very
sad if this was like another isai anime
and the anime was like um this is
[__] I can't do this anymore be like
okay well all right I don't want that
dog [__] show anyway yeah uh but you
know I think cuz it's a show that
everyone is really talking about and
then hearing that all the animators are
really struggling it's like okay oh this
is kind of [__] up also [__] up that
it takes a show like this to people to
kind of care yeah it's [__] up and I
think you know the Silver Lining is that
because I guess K is so big because this
thing has been prevalent in the anime
industry for [__] since the beginning
of anime basically um and it feels like
now more people are getting aware of it
and more people are talking about it
than ever before just because of how big
is and also the animation is absolutely
[__] batshit insanely good yeah uh in
this new season that I think everyone is
like jiit K is no longer mid you have
to it's it was before but I swear to God
it's so far beyond I'm not going to
support a show that punishes animators
actually so okay all
right okay it feels it feels almost bad
like uh like foring over the animation
and saying how amazing it is and then
equally knowing
what is what is the
costen uh but [__] me it's so good and I
I hate that it's so good because I I
feel so bad for these animators but
and's like what can we do what can they
can they strike it's like I mean uh I
mean if you do then you're not going to
get a new episode string has happened in
Japan uh but it is very rare yes and
it's not very effective uh it's yeah
it's very debatable how how effective it
is in Japan um unfortunately because
having a lot of people online I think
they're just churning through that's
this kind of shitty thing right is that
like it's not this isn't really an issue
that average watch what can the average
is there anything the average anime VI
can do except for just be more aware of
it I think I think the only way that it
will change is if like the actual
industry itself just kind of does a top
down reshuffling of just how but that
doesn't happen in Japan because they
love tradition I mean the thing is I
think this goes beyond just like the
anime industry of course that's like one
example of the entertainment industry
it's just like you know it's one
Japanese work culture and expectation
and it's and it there needs to be a
change from a systematic level um I I
feel there's there's not so much the
average person can do which kind of like
sucks cuz you kind of feel helpless but
this issue runs really really [__]
deep yeah um totally but we got we got
good anime right
yeah [__]
ah crazy but hey Gojo's popping
off so fast duno was wild oh God it is
insane it is actually you should watch
it I mean I've seen the gear yeah uh
yeah like the animation I feel like it's
been I don't know
how each episode has been some the
coolest [__] I've ever seen you know
yeah I I I I almost feel that I think
you said this to me off camera you said
that if if if we were doing anime fights
of the Year all the nominations would be
Jitsu kais oh yeah the the best fights
of the year was is jju in fighting
against itself yeah
it's it is shocking the only one who can
defeat me is me so like when you watch
an anime it almost feels like normally
there's this natural like cycle where
it's it builds up and there's a one big
fight where there's a lot of like a lot
of crazy animation going on and then
you're like okay cool I can I can kind
of decompress and's like hey every
episode we
you're like okay what the [__] and every
single like oh my God okay Jesus oh my
[__] oh wow holy sh what it's it's it's
just crazy yeah and I heard like from
the manga readers that the biggest fight
of the Ark isn't even like close to here
yet it's there's that there's an even
bigger fight that's coming and I'm like
what we've had like three four amazing
Banger fights already and then there's
there's still more to come all the
animators just
like I mean I mean this might age poorly
because we don't know know what the
quality of future episodes is going to
be I would just rather them delay it I'd
rather them just not release this uh if
it if it's costing this but obviously
there's no shot that's happening there's
no shot that's happening unfortunately
it's it's too big yeah I would rather
them delay it as well I think everyone I
think I 90 90% of people 99 would would
agree that they'd rather just the show
be done in in a correct way where people
aren't have feeling that they have to go
and complain on Twitter but they're also
going to if they want to get that result
they on a Hiatus at a Good's always
going be two sides of the
opinion they can't win I don't know if
if you saw G but uh Invincible uh it's
after episode 4 of this season 2 oh yeah
it's going on a hius oh really for until
2024 and people on Twitter were like
that's [__] up and there was like tons
of tweets doing really well that were
just kind of like this what the [__]
what's the point of this right and then
it it was why are they going on hi
uh I I think it's cuz they to give the
animators time I think it's I think it's
should to give I think I I mean could
you check this guy yeah I hearing it I
mean that's good cuz I haven't started
season two yet so and it does suck cuz
you're like man halfway through a season
sucks yeah you kind of wish that I would
I would have been completely okay with
them just delaying the whole season I
kind of prefer the season being delayed
and getting it all in one go but I
understand um yep but yeah so it's going
on a bit of a break okay and it's like
people
I understand now I shows are very
reluctant to do this cuz the reaction
was just like they were like what the
[__] why would you [__] do that mway
so [__] up uh and it's just kind of
like sad you're like I think if you if
you explain it in a way audiences
receptive but sometimes that just like
now I want show now yeah but have you
considered the fact I don't care and I
just want the next episode which is
shitty thing to do but it happens yeah I
I mean I feel like like a lot of this
can be offset a bit with better planning
I don't know like I I feel like a lot of
this uh we're not part of the industry
we're just speculating at this point you
know like a lot of this I feel comes
from like you know someone high up top
being like we it would be nice to uh get
our show out in this schedule yeah and
then the people actually working on the
show are like this can't be done or this
will be done very very this poorly we
would have to like kill ourselves uh and
then somehow they deliver it then the
top people are like we can do this again
let's let's keep doing
it so it's it's just like a kind of like
a negative kind of feedback loop where
nothing improves uh yeah as you said
that I think in order for anything to
change at this point you know whether it
be Western animation or the anime
industry like there just needs to be a
top- down remodeling of just how the
system works so that it's fair for
everyone people don't complain as much
and we still get a good you know product
at the end of the day but hey easier
said than done it's not not going to
happen anytime [__] soon
unfortunately yeah um but yeah unfort it
feels like kind of like uh bit of sweet
to talk about how good Jiu-Jitsu kaon 2
is just because we know of the things
going on behind the scenes but still you
know curious to see what the rest of the
season is going to be like we'll see how
it goes I guess you want the most ironic
case I've seen all year Z 100 oh yeah Z
100 the show happened it's on like it
was on like permanent Hiatus indefinite
Hiatus what
yeah it only it only got to episode 9 or
something I believe yeah yeah
yeah which like tell me the irony of a
show showcasing production issues yeah
production issues apparently a ton of
the animators quit right was they're
releasing the rest in December or
something I think it's oh they're
releasing the rest in December the rest
is finishing by Christmas or something
oh okay yeah yeah Jesus but it's been on
hius for quite a while now like a couple
months yeah okay I've said 10 okay so
okay so it's not on they went they just
took a [__] fat Hiatus which oh jeez
which is like interesting cuz I don't
think we've ever had like a mid season
hi us this long before for any show8 86
it oh yeah it it sucks to uh see this
but hopefully this will maybe like you
know if if this kind of stuff happens
and if the audience kind of isn't
receptive to it and a lot of people
don't watch because you know a lot of
people are going to fall off because of
this cuz you know they're not going to
they're not going to wait around
[Music]
hopefully that kind of feedback gets to
the executives who are making these
decisions who are trying to rush things
out they're like look the last time we
tried to rush this out it [__] blew
up in our faces let's let's try and do
this properly next time